[Music]  I'm doing good I mean it's good days and  bad days but Shawn is such an amazing  man and he really is love of my life and  I truly hope one day that we can work it  out and get back together and I think  there is hope and my biggest thing is I  just want to live the rest of our lives  happen hopefully that's together maybe  it's not but right now I'm just focusing  on me and killing me and I think I kind  of lost me now I want to find me said it  sucked  yeah it says so I'm not gonna lie it's  like the Berbick words for and I want to  make it sound nicer prettier but it says  he was actually my first text yesterday  he's a mother's day I was like we go on  and off right now we're talking  I thought I could play soccer plays but  I just can't I don't understand why I  have to walk on eggshells with him with  the sweating it's like absolutely  [Music]